denn jetzt geht es um mal corona heute
gabs bundespressekonferenz corona update
das wenn sie hier live gesehen und
werden für sie noch einmal die
wichtigsten aussagen zusammengefasst
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
äußert sich übrigens auch zu einer
vierten impfung für die risikogruppe es
ist leider keine gute situation mit der
wir zurzeit konfrontiert sind die
pandemie ist bei weitem nicht vorbei
also von einem frieden de kann keine
rede sein ganz im gegenteil zum einen
wir müssen unbedingt die
hotspot regelung die mit dem neuen
infektionsschutzgesetz gekommen ist
müssen wir auch nutzen die ungeimpften
müssen sich vor augen führen dass sie
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt der ansteckung so
gut wie nicht mehr entgehen können wir
haben eine so hohe fallzahl dass alle
die jetzt um games sind damit rechnen
müssen sich in den nächsten tagen zu
infizieren das ist leider die situation
die also in die man kann im moment der
infektion kaum ausreichen ich glaube
dass wir hier mehr tun könnten wir
könnten hier zum einen auf diejenigen
die von der stiko jetzt abgedeckt sind
offensiver zu gehen sagen die vierte
impfung hilfen ist hier notwendig ich
glaube aber auch dass wir auf diejenigen
zugehen sollten zumindest in der
altersgruppe 60 bis 70 die
risikofaktoren haben von denen wir
wissen dass sie das sterberisiko für
kurz- und für den schweren verlauf
deutlich erhöhen und zugeschaltet ist
jetzt tino sorge gesundheitspolitischer
sprecher der cdu csu fraktion schön dass
sie hier sind schönen guten tag wenn sie
denn der gesundheitsminister so sprechen
hören ist das für sie ihr panikmache
oder eine realistische einschätzung der
situation
ja ich hätte mir gewünscht dass er aus
dem modus angst minister einen modus
gesundheitsminister umgeschaltet und da
haben wir heute wieder erlebt dass
teilweise auch brauchen aufgestellt
wurden die wissenschaftlich fragwürdig
sind die frage der anzahl der
infektionen zu sagen da 1000 sind
bewiesen oder belegt und die
dunkelziffer liege ungefähr bei doppelt
so hoch ist mehr oder weniger anekdoten
evidenz das ist so nicht belegbar aber
auch bei der frage wann und jemand
beispielsweise ist zitierte impfungen
hat er sich ja ganz klar von der
empfehlung der stiko abgesetzt die
gesagt hatte 70 gruppen herr lauterbach
meint jetzt die vierte impfung bereits
jetzt auch schon für ab 60 jährige zu
geben und ich halte das auch wenn man
sich mit biologen unterhält
wissenschaftlich für fragwürdig
insbesondere vor dem hintergrund dass
wir ja die drei monate oder antikörper
status sehr hohes nutzen müssen das
heißt diejenigen die es das vierte mal
geimpft würden hätten auch im herbst
dann nicht den schutz das heißt wir
müssten im herbst eine fünfte impfung
nachdenken deshalb wäre es sinnvoll
jetzt über eine impfkampagne zu sprechen
anstatt schon wieder in dissenz auch
über die frage herbeizuführen das ist
ein gutes stichwort denn das gibt es ja
auch immer noch über die impfpflicht
auch ihre partei hat sich ja mal so und
mal so positioniert heute jetzt an
diesem tag wie stehen sie zu einer
impfpflicht lohnt sich das noch ja ich
würde sie da ungern korrigieren aber wir
haben als union immer gesagt dass ihr
einen kompromiss unterbreiten werden
weil es ja in allen fraktionen der fall
ist dass es da sehr unterschiedliche
auffassungen gibt also und auch
auffassung die wissenschaftlich ja sehr
unterschiedlich sind bei der frage ob es
überhaupt sinnvoll ist alle ab 18
pauschal zu impfen gehen die meinungen
weit auseinander also deshalb haben wir
als fraktion ja auch gesagt wir brauchen
erstmal eine datengrundlage stichwort
ins register und die wohltaten in
gruppen muss man ins in den blick nehmen
es geht irgendwie ja überlastung oder
drohende überlastung dass man die
vermeidet im gesundheitssystem und da
geht es tatsächlich darum die
signifikanten gruppen zu identifizieren
und nicht in dem wissen dass wir zwar
sehr viele infektionen neuinfektionen
haben mit sehr vielen milden also gar
keinen schweren verläufen dass wir da
tatsächlich die die gruppen
identifizieren die den unterschied
machen und deshalb liegt der kompromiss
des seitens der union auf dem tisch es
ist schade dass die letzten wochen sich
daher karl lauterbach und die allgemeine
wehrpflicht befürworter nicht bewegt
haben aber wir werden sehen wie die
beratung ausgehen immerhin ist der
gesundheitsminister ja noch voller
optimismus dass man sich am ende auf
irgendeine art kompromiss einigen wird
zum thema impfpflicht sind hier genauso
optimistisch
wer im grunde liegt der kompromiss auf
dem tisch also wir haben ja etwa die
zwischen impfpflicht für alle quasi ohne
differenzierung wo ja auch die
wissenschaft sagt dass es auch von der
wahrscheinlichkeit bei der infektion
einen schweren verlauf zu bekommen für
bestimmte alterskohorten überhaupt nicht
so hohe risiken gibt also stichwort
jüngere menschen da muss man
differenzieren das ist auch
verfassungsrechtlich geboten und
letztendlich ist es durchaus ein problem
jetzt zu sagen man beschließt pauschal
quasi auf vorrat eine impfpflicht obwohl
im jahr individuell sehr nützlich ist
also hill vor schweren verläufen aber
man beschließt eine impfpflicht auf
vorrat für eine variante die wir noch
nicht kennen mit einem impfstoff der
überhaupt noch nicht verfügbar ist also
da geht es um abwägung von grundrechten
und da einfach mal so einzugreifen
das halte ich für falsch und deshalb
haben wir sehr differenziert als union
ein kompromissvorschlag untergrund also
ich glaub markus söder hier das ganz
lange genauso für richtig aber da
brauchen wir uns gar nicht ins detail
gehen es liegt erstmal ein kompromiss
vor interessanter ist wie geht es weiter
wir erwarten einen freedom day aber
irgendwie glaubt keiner mehr so richtig
daran gleichzeitig ist ja klar am
zweiten april wird sich ganz viel ändern
dennoch gibt es sonder ausnahmen nämlich
dann für hot spots die werden aber nicht
mehr den schwellenwerten fest gemacht
sondern beispielsweise an den lagen in
den krankenhäusern dann kann aber auch
ein ganzes bundesland mehr oder weniger
wieder maßnahmen ein bisschen fast zu
dicht machen auf jeden fall massen in
den schulen also all das was wir alle
schon viel zu gut kennen einführen
glauben sie dass das der richtige weg
ist für uns jetzt wir haben ja die
groteske situation dass der
bundesjustizminister auch bei der frage
der hotspots eine ganz andere auffassung
hat als der bundesgesundheitsminister
die länder die sich ja im übrigen am
montag in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz wieder
treffen der haben ja auch nach
verabschiedung diese änderungen
infektionsschutzgesetz gesagt das geht
so nicht weil es viel zu unklar ist also
die frage was kann ein hotspot sein das
sagt ihr carlotta war da kann man
pauschal ein ganzes bundesland am
hotspot erklären und gegen
bundesjustizminister ja ganz klar gesagt
hat dass sie zu nicht auch bei der
güterabwägung da muss geschaut werden ob
beispielsweise lokale
belastungssituationen drohen und dann
kann man aber nicht pauschal sagen das
ganze bundesland wird anführungsstrichen
nicht gemacht sondern dann muss man über
maßnahmen nachdenken also kann man
patienten verlegen beispielsweise von
einem ort in den anderen und nachts über
zwei jahren pandemie halte ich es für
angebracht auch jetzt nicht mehr mit
pauschallösung zu agieren und
insbesondere dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister
endlich seine hausaufgaben macht mit den
ländern spricht und nicht diese
unsicherheit dadurch erzeugt dass er
gesetze auf den weg bringt die viel zu
spät kommen die nicht das halten was sie
versprechen und zum schluss gibt es dann
innerhalb der koalition noch
diskussionen über die auslegung des
gesetzes und dann sollen die länder
quasi in einer op tenz wissen was
justizminister oder gesundheitsminister
gemeint haben wenn die sich nicht mal
einige sind ja das ist schwierig zu
durchblicken vor allem wenn der
gesundheitsminister sagt das eigentlich
schwellenwerte überhaupt gar nicht mehr
aussagekräftig sind gleichzeitig stehen
diese drohnen zahlen im raum über
300.000 neuinfektionen gleichzeitig über
die aussage eigentlich tauben diese
zahlen überhaupt nichts und über
hotspots ist man sich auch nicht so ganz
im klaren was wäre ihr vorschlag was
sollte unser staffel system oder
meinetwegen eine zahl oder eine
situation sein anhand derer wir uns
einen maßnahmen orientieren können
ja wir haben ja bestimmte indikatoren
die viel aussagekräftiger sind also die
reine neue infektionszahlen der reine
incidents wert ist ja wenig aussagefähig
wenn wir sehr viele infektionen haben
wir reden von 300.000 einer gewissen
dunkelziffer
gleichzeitig aber sehr wenige schwere
verläufe auch in den krankenhäusern in
den intensivstationen keinerlei
überlastung situation aus dann wäre es
durchaus angebracht auch zu sagen nikon
hat die karten neu gemischt wir können
da auch ein bisschen hoffnungsfroher
vorangehen wir müssen in der diskussion
auch das thema absonderung regeln
quarantäne regelungen in den blick
nehmen dass wir uns diese überlastung
situation spricht dass viele menschen
einfach weil sie symptome frei sich
testen positiv getestet sind und dann
pauschal in quarantäne gehen dass wir
darüber nachdenken weil wir auch darüber
sprechen müssen inwieweit das überhaupt
sinnvoll ist also es macht ja keinen
sinn wenn in bereichen menschen gerne
arbeiten würden arbeiten können einer
leistung haben und dann aber zu hause
bleiben müssen anstatt im home office
oder auch in bereichen wo keine ruhe ab
in gruppen sind weiter arbeiten wenn
also da erwarte ich mir auch ein
bisschen pragmatische ansätze die ja
auch wissenschaftlich
begründbar sind wo wir auch sehen dass
die virologen sagen da kann man durchaus
realistischer mit umgehen und ihn nicht
ihr eine inzidenz immer nur sehen die
ansteckungszahlen bei die im übrigen ja
auch ein argument dafür werden weil bei
300.000 neuinfektionen
im bezug dazu relativ wenigen toten
obwohl jeder tote ein tor dazu vieles
aber auch die frage ob es dann immer
noch zielführend ist komplett wieder
alles runter zu fahren das halte ich für
einen fehler dann müssen wir auch
pragmatische umgehen damit letzte frage
ein sehr glauben sie dass es uns jetzt
endlich mal gelungen ist die kinder mehr
im blick zu haben die situation an den
schulen in den kitas mehr im blick zu
haben
der punkt ist es extrem wichtig weil wir
ja gesehen haben zu beginn der handel
relativ wenig auch über die wirkweise
des virus wussten war dass vertretbar
aber diese ganzen kollateralschäden also
die schäden die dadurch entstehen dass
man eher mit gröberen maßnahmen versucht
und ein ziel zu erreichen da müssen wir
bei der güterabwägung genauer hinschauen
also die frage ist es sinnvoll dass
kinder in schulen grundsätzlich immer
maske tragen oder das ständig getestet
wird da müssen wir auch die
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse
berücksichtigen und auch bei der frage
wie hoch ist das risiko ein kind das
sich infizieren also da wo auch die
schweren verläufe viel viel geringer
sein muss man auch abwägen ob man in
zweifel bei den kindern vielleicht noch
nicht so doll aber gerade bei älteren
beziehungsweise normal alten menschen
darüber nachdenkt mehr eigene
verantwortung wieder den menschen zu
geben und nicht zu glauben der staat
könne jegliches lebensrisiko vom bürger
schützen sagt tino sorge
gesundheitspolitischer sprecher der cdu
csu fraktion herzlichen danke ihnen für
das gespräch